le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais avoir un enfant peut
provoquer chez la maman un sentiment
inexplicable un mélange d'émotion forte
entre joie bonheur douleur et
responsabilité la priorité d'une maman
est de s'occuper comme il faut de son
bébé de lui offrir les soins dont il a
besoin parfois la situation de la maman
rend les soins du bébé difficil
femme seule conflit familial situation
financière et aussi problèm de santé du
nouveau né les mamans qui sont dans ce
cas peuvent être parfois pris d'angoisse
et de culpabilité car elles ne trouvent
pas les solutions adaptées au soins de
leurs enfants alors qui est capable de
soutenir les mamans dans ce cas
existe-t-il des services sociaux pouvant
répondre au soins des bébés on en parle
maintenant dans lien
social
Josie est maman d'une très jolie petite
fille de 2 ans après l'accouchement sa
fille Nora avait quelques difficulté
pour dormir et pleurer plus que la
normale comme toutes les mamans Josie
était fatigué de sa grossesse et de
l'accouchement en maman responsable et
bienveillante pour son enfant Josie a
cherché des solutions pour aider sa
fille elle a appris qu'elle pouvait
s'adresser à la PMI la Protection
Maternelle et Infantile un service du
conseil général très efficace qui
apporte de l'aide aux jeunes mamans et
leurs enfants la famère puricultrice
auscultait mon bébé c'est-à-dire elle
prenait le poids la taille
elle vérifiait aussi la motricité
elle prenait aussi des nouvelles sur la
façon dont je nourrissais mon enfant me
donnait des conseils dans la manière de
nourrir des conseils aussi dans l'éveil
de mon enfant médecin c'était aussi
pesé vérifier la
motricité l'éveille aussi un peu si mon
enfant était éveillé et je pense aussi
bon voir si moi en tant que parent ben
j'assumais très bien mon rôle et
elle m'a aussi conseillé aussi dans le
choix du mode de garde de mon enfant
donc elle m'a parce que pendant ma
grossesse j'avais inscrite ma fille dans
une crèche
malheureusement enfin comme beaucoup
beaucoup de parents j'avais pas eu de
place donc encore une fois la PMI était
là pour me me conseiller sur bah le
choix d'une assistante maternelle et
elle
m'a elle m'a donné le numéro de
téléphone d'une assistante maternelle et
ça a été de suite le coup de foudre
entre l'assistante et ma fille
exactement
c'est soins de conseils d' d'aide et et
aussi m'a suivi dans la vie de tous les
jours et aussi la PMI c'est un peu aussi
un aussi un rôle
de où c'est un endroit où je pouvais
aussi raconter un peu mes états
d'âes dans ma relation avec mon
enfant en acceptant le soutien de la PMI
Josie a trouvé des réponses aux
questions qu'elle se posait sur la façon
d'élever son enfant elle y a trouvé des
conseils de professionnel au service des
jeunes mamans la i lui a aussi offert du
réconfort un endroit où elle pouvait se
confier et ainsi se sentir plus sereine
quant à l'avenir de sa petite fille
aujourd'hui Josie est une maman épanouie
au grand bonheur de sa fille Nora la PMI
est un service du conseil général placé
sous la l'autorité et la responsabilité
de la présidente du conseil général la
PMI c'est un service qui est dirigé par
un médecin chef qui coordonne en fait
des équipes pluridisciplinaires où on
regroupe on va dire 200 agents il a il y
a des médecins des sagesfemmes des
puricultrices des auxilires
puricultrices mais également euh ben ce
ce personnel là qui justement accompagne
les mères futur mèr je et puis également
les enfants il y a peu quand même une
aide au niveau au niveau de ses équipes
au niveau de la PMI dans la PMI mais
également à domicile également à
l'hôpital ça permet justement à ses
équipes d'accompagner les parents mais
également les enfants surtout au point
de vue santé et puis bien évidment un
lien qui est très important au niveau du
conseil général c'est ce lien paren
enfant avec environ 14000 naissances sur
le département chaque année la Réunion
est une île dynamique en terme de
natalité le Conseil Général soutient les
jeunes maman dès leur grossesse avec la
PMI un service efficace très proche de
la population la PMI propose une
panoplie d'aide et de service utile et
nécessairire à l'équilibre des familles
réunionnaises depuis sa création ce
service ne cesse d'évoluer avec le souci
de répondre toujours mieux aux besoins
des Réunionnais comme cela s'est passé
pour Josie et Nora la volonté de la
présidente du conseil général est de
renforcer les liens indispensables au
bon équilibre des familles et à l'avenir
de nos enfants c'est pourquoi le Conseil
Général promeut la santé pour tous
au-delà des obligations légales portant
sur la Protection Maternelle et
Infantile de nombreux dispositifs sont
proposés aux familles réunionnaises en
terme de suivi médical des femmes et des
mais aussi d'information sur les
maladies chroniques de désaccoutumance
au diverses addictions tous ces
dispositifs sont présentés dans les
différents points info santé ou dans le
cadre de manifestation comme les
journées
santé le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais